who do we want control of the most
dangerous substances
we've abdicated control what you've
described is exactly the anarchy we have
right now is the people who control
drugs in the united states is not the
government
we just play reactive ball to whatever
the cartels are doing
and so
we know you know
i've heard this
and
this has been the standard mantra you
know we're arresting all these low-level
drug dealers because we're working our
way up to the kingpin but we get the
kingpin and all we do is we fragment the
market
and now there's a fight for that market
share and then you see the uptick in
violence
so why are we allowing the worst actors
who don't care about community health
and safety
to control that really dangerous
market i don't think it's going to make
a difference let me explain why
so let's say you
legalize it
okay
what does
what do politicians in the white house
love doing their favorite day of the
year is april 15th sure they love
increasing taxes exactly so what happens
if they increase taxes so the same weed
i could buy
that's legal from walmart or cvs is
always going to be
50 percent higher 40 percent higher than
me being able to sell it illegally so
even if you legalize it the drug dealer
is going to still have the edge to sell
at half the price that the government's
selling because taxes are going to be
increased they'll have moonshine
so let's just put this myth to bad
that we are ever going to eliminate
crime completely or drugs completely in
our society we're never even going to
eliminate the mafia completely we did a
really good job once alcohol prohibition
ended and then what we have to do is
where i do agree with kiki is let's do
strategic policing and take out those
actors that are causing the most harm in
our society right
but
from a liberty perspective
as americans
we are never going to be a crime-free
society we're never going to be a
drug-free society we're always going to
have to deal with these issues and so we
have to look at policy in the in the
sense of how do we mitigate the most
harms
without turning into a state where we're
killing people and no knock warrants
over drugs or police officers are losing
their lives so so did you have a
response to her or what i said about
taxes
uh no i agree with you totally that it's
going to be taxed it's going to be
expensive to buy the drugs
and the cartels are going to make them
available at a cheaper rate that's
what's going to happen you're going to
have the cartels
basically competing
with
the uh the government that's going to
tax them yeah because i mean you know
look
that's the drug dealer's model he's
going to be like look how much are they
charging at cvs how much is that at
walgreens no problem i'll give it to you
for half the price because i'm getting
volume and i'm bringing it for south or
central america if you enjoyed this
short clip give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch the whole thing click over here